durante años argelia fue uno de los
países más estables del norte de áfrica
no sólo era un aliado estratégico para
occidente en la lucha contra el
terrorismo y con un papel de liderazgo a
la hora de mantener la seguridad en el
sahel también era un país con una
economía estimulada por la abundancia de
recursos naturales como el petróleo y el
gas
argelia estaba entre los 20 países del
mundo que producía más crudo sin embargo
la economía se ha estancado en los
últimos años desde 2014 el precio del
petróleo cayó en picado y argelia que
dependía de las exportaciones de crudo
vio como esas ganancias se redujeron a
la mitad en dos años con el descenso
correspondiente del pib
al mismo tiempo su gobierno ha tenido
dificultades para crear trabajos en
otros sectores con el desempleo
oscilando entre el 11 y el 12 por ciento
desde hace cuatro años los más afectados
los jóvenes del país que representan el
70% de la población cerca de un tercio
de ellos están sin trabajo los jóvenes
han sido críticos con la corrupción del
sector público de argelia y de líderes
empresariales en 2019 esa insatisfacción
estalló en las protestas más intensas
vistas en el país desde su independencia
en 1962 el llamado movimiento gira --que
terminó derrocando abdelaziz buteflika
el hombre que había dirigido el país
durante 20 años los manifestantes
incluso protestaron contra el gobierno
interino al que acusaban de impulsar
sólo cambios cosméticos
a raíz de la pandemia de coronavirus las
condiciones económicas sólo han
empeorado con una caída de las
exportaciones del 30% en 2020
una inmensa brecha económica entre ricos
y pobres el alto costo de la vida y la
depreciación de la moneda han dejado las
autoridades con un reto gigante frente a
unas elecciones legislativas largamente
postergadas no solo en términos de
mejorar la vida de los argelinos sino
también de reconstruir la confianza rota
entre el gobierno y el pueblo